OK.
You can participate in a respectful political
discussions on the David Pakman show.
Subbrand it at David Pakman dot com slash
RFD DHT.
A few interesting posts I spotted this morning.
There is a new poll which indicates that 50
percent of Americans believe Joe Biden is
too liberal.
What I think is really interesting about this
is that you right now have completely opposite
claims being made about Joe Biden, the right.
Every day this week at the Republican National
Convention has been insisting that if Joe
Biden wins, he will affect his socialist Marxist
ideology on the country.
And we won't have capitalism and a little
out of that.
Right.
You understand the way that that goes.
The progressive left, meanwhile, is displeased
that Joe Biden is not really very left.
Now, what's the truth?
There is some empirical reality here.
And the empirical reality is that Joe Biden,
generally speaking, is a center left candidate
who as a sign of the times, because it's 20/20
and not 2012 or 2008 or 1993, as some people
like to point to when they talk about Joe
Biden's beliefs.
Joe Biden has adopted elements of what Bernie
Sanders wants on climate and the economy,
of what AOC would like to see in the Green
New Deal.
And so in the broader global context, if you
put Biden on a political spectrum that includes
Europe, for example, Biden is center left
ish.
And if you compare Biden's platforms to those
of previous American presidents, he is the
most progressive on a bunch of issues.
But that doesn't mean that much.
When you compare him to people like Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama, et cetera.
That's the reality.
Somehow, half the country thinks Biden is
too far left.
That tells you a little bit about how the
United States compares politically to many
other parts of the world user karaoke.
Twenty three asked after posting some videos
of some protests.
How are these people going to react if Trump
loses?
I am going to address this in detail on tomorrow's
program, and I'm going to look at which electoral
scenario in November is the most likely to
lead to violence and who is likely to be doing
the violence.
I don't believe it's hyperbolic to be thinking
about it.
I don't believe it's hyperbolic to be concerned
I think there is a real possibility for violence.
And listen, I'm going to be talking about
Kyle Rittenhouse, the 17 year old who started
shooting people in Wisconsin.
OK.
The violence is already happening.
And I think it's quite possible Donald Trump
will weaponize and coalesce that more of that
violence depending on the results.
Lastly, user Knife-edge or asks, is Jimmy
from Philly for real?
I just listened to the segment on David's
YouTube channel.
Until recently, I genuinely thought this was
a real guy with real delusions.
But segments like this make me wonder, is
this a character?
I'm new here, but I'm sure this question guest
gets asked all the time on this sub Reddit.
I am here to tell you, Jimmy from Philly is
very real.
It is not a character that he is playing.
And I know that we often wonder sometimes
people are so out there that it's a natural
question to say, is this a character?
How can someone like this even get through
the day?
How can someone like this survive into adulthood?
Quite frankly, a bit.
Jimmy from Philly is real.
He is a trumpet.
He is a furious Trampas.
And there is every indication that he is completely
genuine in the beliefs he espouses.
And that's a very scary thing, because, as
I said before, even if Trump loses in November,
we will still have more than 60 million people
who will have voted for Trump.
And that's something we will have to deal
with.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it.
More than 20000 of you have subscribed over
on Reddit, making us one of the largest progressive
media sub credits on the Internet.
An incredible accolade.